zdf heute live herzlich willkommen an
diesem dienstagabend wir schauen nach
trier wo ein mann am frühen nachmittag
mit seinem auto in der fußgängerzone
mehrere menschen erfasst hat die polizei
spricht von mehreren toten nach jüngsten
angaben sind es mindestens vier darunter
offenbar auch ein kind von mindestens 15
verletzten ist die rede
nach verschiedenen medienberichten auch
von 30 toten darunter er ist 30
schwerverletzte entschuldigung 30
verletzte darunter auch schwerverletzte
so der trierer oberbürgermeister sagte
journalisten vor ort ist handele sich um
einen amok fall von terror ist bislang
von seiten der behörden nicht die rede
und seit etwa einer stunde seit 15 uhr
51 hat die polizei entwarnung gegeben
nach der festnahme des autofahrers
bestehe keine gefahr für die trierer
bevölkerung
wir sehen bilder aus der trierer
innenstadt von heute mittag ein
großaufgebot von polizei und
rettungskräften war im einsatz
augenzeugen berichten von schrecklichen
bildern menschen seien durch die luft
geflogen gegenstände auch bürgermeister
wolfram leibe
bei seiner ersten konferenz zu konferenz
die heute gegeben hat hatte tränen in
den augen konnte als einer der ersten am
tatort seien und erzählte von anblicken
die ihn sehr berührt haben zitat da
steht ein turnschuh eines mädchens und
das mädchen ist tot
das also erste eindrücke aus der trierer
innenstadt wir hören auch dass die
ministerpräsidentin von rheinland pfalz
auf dem weg nach trier ist um sich dort
ein bild der lage zu verschaffen
es gibt bilder von der festnahme des
mutmaßlichen täters die wir hier zeigen
können
der wagen sei sichergestellt worden der
mutmaßliche täter ein 51 jahre alter
mann ein deutscher aus dem kreis trier
saarburg sei festgenommen worden
in trier bin ich jetzt verbunden mit dem
lokal reporter lukas blasius vom city
radio trierer blasius ich hoffe sie
können dich hören und wir können
zumindest teil von ihnen sehen daher
blasius können sie uns einen eindruck
vermitteln von dem was heute in trier
passiert ist hat auch guten abend also
das ganze hier war ein drunter und
drüber ein ziemliches chaos zuerst mal
es hat am nachmittag angefangen dass die
einsatzwagen ihr rund um die porta an
der wir hier auch unser funkhaus haben
unterwegs waren und die situation war
zunächst sehr unklar bis dann die
polizei trier über twitter bestätigt hat
was sie geben auch schon gesagt haben
dass es sich hier um eine amokfahrt
handelt mit vielen verletzten und wohl
auch erstmal zunächst zwei klein war nun
wohl doch mindestens vier toten
die ereignisse haben sich sehr schnell
überschlagen und mittlerweile kehrt ein
klein wenig ruhe ein
man sieht von hier aus auch in die
innenstadt dort ist immer noch sehr sehr
viel blaulicht sehr viele einsatzkräfte
auch unterwegs und nachdem zunächst ein
großes drunter und drüber war scheint
sich die lage nun so langsam zu ordnen
trotzdem ist man hier natürlich sehr
sehr mitgenommen das ganze hat die leute
und hat direkt und schon sehr getroffen
können sie für alle die die trierer
innenstadt nicht kennen ein bisschen
beschreiben wie es dort aussieht und
auch wie sie an einem tag wie heute
aussieht das gilt ja jetzt noch einmal
verschärfte corona auflagen man ist
davon man kann davon ausgehen dass
eigentlich gar nicht so viele menschen
unterwegs waren oder sind oder wie sah
die innenstadt an einem frühen
nachmittag aus können sie das
beschreiben
ja das sollte man meinen dass nicht
viele menschen unterwegs sind aber trotz
der krone auflagen ist die trierer
innenstadt auch gerade in den letzten
tagen sehr gut besucht gewesen
in der vorweihnachtszeit ist es ein
beliebtes anlaufziel normalerweise für
touristen dienen natürlich weniger da
sind aber sonst natürlich auch für viele
privatleute die ihr einkauf von ihren
erledigungen nachgehen oder einfach nur
nach
etwas zeitvertreib suchen und auch aus
dem benachbarten luxemburg kommen
natürlich sehr viele menschen über die
grenze hier nach trier um im sinne der
großregion auch hier die innenstadt zu
genießen und hier einkaufen zu gehen
deswegen ist auch dann an am
dienstagnachmittag die heute in der
stadt schon durchaus einiges los gewesen
man kann davon ausgehen dass viele leute
in der stadt waren vielleicht nicht ganz
so viele wie normalerweise zu dem
weihnachtsmarkt hier gewesen wären
wer nun eigentlich hätte stattfinden
sollen auch immer geschützt ist mit
dickem beton pollern da kann man schon
in dem sinne ja ein wenig glücklich sein
dass dort nicht noch größere
menschenmengen anwesend waren trotzdem
natürlich schrecklich dass so viele
leute von dieser tat betroffen sind
da haben wir das machen wir eine ganz
kurze pause denn wir möchten gerne
jemandem die chance geben zu berichten
was heute passiert ist wir konnten
nämlich mit jemandem sprechen eine
augenzeugin elena hertel austria sie ist
17 jahre alt
mit einverständnis ihrer eltern durften
wir mit ihr sprechen und sie kann ganz
genau berichten was sie dort heute
nachmittag erlebt hat es ist schwer zu
beschreiben ich war sehr geschockt ich
konnte das irgendwie gar nicht
realisieren dass das jetzt wirklich so
passiert ist also für mich noch gar
nicht wirklich wahrheit ja ich habe mir
das dann irgendwie angeguckt und als
dann immer mehr verletzte menschen
wurden ja brauchen wir ein bisschen die
panik aus weil ich eben nicht wusste was
genau das war weil wir davon nichts
mitbekommen hatten und ich wollte
irgendwie einfach nur probieren schnell
weg
und irgendwie meine familie angerufen ob
es einem gut geht und meine freunde weil
ich eben auch mir natürlich nicht sicher
sein konnte dass da jemand dabei war der
eben verletztes den ich natürlich auch
sehr gut kenne und ich glaube es einfach
so der geschockte zustand ich habe
angefangen zu zittern aber trotzdem
wirklich ich habe es nicht realisiert
und ist jetzt gerade auch noch nicht
ganz klar für mich dass das eben so
passiert ist sagte härtel austria
es geht darum den verletzten zu helfen
vor ort und es geht darum allen menschen
zu helfen die vehlener hertel heute das
mittal miterlebt haben und das waren
allererste eindrücke die sie jetzt
geschildert hat ein blasses wir wissen
alle das kann man nicht so leicht
verarbeiten und das wird lange brauchen
bis man überhaupt so eine 1 1
geschehnisse verarbeiten kann wenn das
überhaupt möglich ist und dazu braucht
es viel zeit und auch viel gute hilfe
was können sie sagen über die leute die
dort heute im einsatz sind vor ort
welche arbeit wurde und wird da jetzt
gerade geleistet
also ich denke dass sie damit sehr recht
haben das ist lange zeit dauern wird so
etwas zu verarbeiten
das hat man auch schon auf den
verschiedenen konferenzen die nun in
kleinsten rahmen stattfinden konnten
auch gemerkt wie auch anfangs bei ihnen
erwähnt der oberbürgermeister wolfram
lade sehr mitgenommen war meine kollegen
auch die auf den konferenzen waren haben
entsprechend auch ja berichten können
das ist doch schon eine schockierte
stimmung ist natürlich und das wird eine
zeit lang brauchen ich denke die
einsatzkräfte die haben heute eine so
weit ich das beurteilen kann und so weit
ich es ansonsten mitbekommen habe eine
sehr gute arbeit gemacht
nach dem anfänglichen chaos wurde dann
doch recht schnell reagiert und es waren
informationen da es wurde scheint bei
der täter auch durchaus schnell gefasst
das auto sichergestellt und entsprechend
auch die ermahnung geben dass nun
scheinbar keine weitere gefahr mehr
besteht was ja auch sehr sehr wichtig
ist außerdem ist hier gleich hinter mir
die innenstadt abgesperrt und ein
großteil der
die entsprechend herumführen sind
derzeit dann auch noch zu das wird auch
wohl noch lange dauern das ist auch sehr
schnell alles abgesperrt worden also in
dem sinne von dem was wir hier auch aus
dem funkhaus heraus erst mal mitbekommen
haben eine gute arbeit die dort
geleistet wurde
wie weit das ganze jetzt dennoch
lückenlos weiterbearbeitet werden kann
muss man natürlich schauen
im ersten moment denke ich wurden wie
richtigen schritte ergriffen
ich nutze kurz die gelegenheit um ein
paar user kommentare zusammenzufassen
andreas schwarz schreibt über facebook
er ist ein überlebender des
breitscheidplatz anschlags natürlich
nicht vergleichbar aber natürlich auch
eine eine tat die sich in das gedächtnis
dieser nation eingebrannt hat herr
schwarz schreibt wir die opfer vom
breitscheidplatz sprechen unser beileid
den opfern austria aus gute besserung
den verletzten personen über youtube
schreibt uns arg in aritz mag es ist
sehr traurig und danny engel schreibt
auch über youtube dieses jahr ist das
schlimmste was ich erlebt habe
anton kramer schreibt über youtube ich
habe eine frage was war der auslöser für
diese handlung erblassers ich weiß es
ist sehr früh und es ist alles auf der
ebene der spekulation aber gibt es
irgendwelche informationen der behörden
der polizei was einen auslöser gegeben
habe was was der auslöser gewesen sein
könnte für diese tat also spekulationen
gibt es natürlich immer eine ganze menge
nicht nur der polizei sondern auch in
der bevölkerung aber wirkliche fakten
dann die man sich halten kann sind
derzeit noch nicht bekannt man weiß das
ist ein 51 jähriger mann aus dem
landkreis trier saarburg war er diese
tat begangen haben soll der festgenommen
wurde zumindest die hintergründe sind
derzeit noch nicht aktiv kommuniziert
worden
es kann derzeit nicht von einem attentat
oder ähnlichem gesprochen werden auch
weitere politische oder religiöse
hintergründe wurden bisher erst mal
nicht zumindest ausgeschlossen aber
zumindest doch nicht weiter verfolgt
oder angesprochen und
in diesem sinne muss man denke ich auch
erst mal den beamten die nötige zeit
lassen das ganze aufzuarbeiten und die
hintergründe klar zu stellen bevor man
da auch wirklich klar sehen kann moment
ist es denke ich einfach für die meisten
menschen sehr unbegreifbar und ich hoffe
dass da auch bei der aufklärung herrscht
kann im moment aber noch nicht mit ganz
konkreten fakten oder beweisen hier auch
nach zutage treten
dann schauen wir mal was der stand im
moment ist wir haben ein statement der
polizei austria gehören gemeinsam mal
rein
ja und heute gegen 13 48 gingen die
ersten notrufe bei der
rettungsleitstelle ein dass in der
fußgängerzone in trier ein auto menschen
überfahren würde was wir bisher wissen
ist dass ein autofahrer aus richtung
konstantinstraße in die brot straße
eingebogen ist dann durch die gesamte
fußgängerzone gefahren ist bisher ans
ende porta nigra unterwegs wahllos
menschen angefahren hat wir konnten
dieses auto dann in der christophstraße
dass es sie haben ende der fußgängerzone
stoppen den fahrer festnehmen
das ist ein 51-jähriger mann ein
deutscher aus dem landkreis trier
saarburg
sofort waren viele einsatzkräfte der
polizei rettungsdienste vor ort wir
können zur motivation dass man es noch
nichts sagen er ist festgenommen er wird
zurzeit vernommen
im moment besteht keine gefahr mehr die
fußgängerzone die innenstadt ist
gesperrt
es ist sehr viel polizei unterwegs die
jetzt die aufgabe haben den tatort zu
untersuchen spuren zu sichern
wir können sagen dass es tote gegeben
hat schwerstverletzte verletzte über die
anzahl kann ich zurzeit noch nicht genau
sagen
herr haasis korrigieren sie mich aber
wenn ich das richtig sehe dann war das
karl peter jochem der sprecher des
polizeipräsidiums in trier der da
aktuelle informationen abgegeben hat
herr blasius können sie uns trier als
kleinstadt mal ein bisschen beschreiben
denn das ist einer dieser fälle wo man
sagt
das kann überall passieren aber doch
nicht bei uns vor der eigenen haustür
also wie ist das gefühl der trierer
jetzt wenige stunden nach dieser tat
trier als gefühlte kleinstadt zumindest
mit rund 120.000 einwohnern zählt es zu
den großstädten ist aber da natürlich
doch eher in der kleineren groß norden
angesiedelt es ist durchaus ein
ich würde sagen familiäres gefühl dass
normalerweise hier in trier herrscht
spruch trier ist ein dorf ist ihr recht
bekannt also man kennt sich
wenn man in der stadt unterwegs ist
trifft man viele bekannte gesichter und
dementsprechend hat man auch oft das
gefühl einer gewissen verbundenheit dass
man eben zusammen zu einer region zu
einer stadt gehört und das auf ganz
verschiedene arten und weisen
dementsprechend denke ich hätten die
wenigsten heute morgen beim aufstehen
auch nur vermuten können dass solch eine
schreckliche tat geschieht wie sie heute
eben geschehen ist die stadt ist
natürlich auch geprägt dadurch dass wir
hier in der großregion der quattropole
leben also mit der brücken luxemburg und
metz in einem verbund aus drei ländern
deutschland luxemburg und frankreich
das ist hier spürbar es ist eine
internationale aber trotzdem durchaus
beschauliche ruhige liegen wird gerade
eigentlich nur zur weihnachtszeit wohin
hatte ich schon mal gesagt wo der
weihnachtsmarkt eigentlich hier in trier
zu einem der schönsten deutschlands
zählt und die stadt sehr sehr
beschaulich macht ist das was heute
geschehen ist natürlich ein riesiger
kontrast dazu
nun ist eine der prominentesten
triererinnen sozusagen auch gleichzeitig
die ministerpräsidentin des landes malu
dreyer
wir schauen mal sie hat getwittert am
nachmittag ich weiß nicht ob wir es
sehen können ich hoffe ja genau da ist
es malu dreyer in einem tweet ich bin
schockiert und tief erschüttert über die
tat in meiner heimatstadt trier
mein tiefes beileid gilt den angehörigen
der toten allen verletzten wünsche ich
dass sie bald und schnell genesen
danke an alle einsatzkräfte ich bin
gleich in trier
also sie wird dort im laufe des frühen
abends erwartet und dann sicherlich auch
ein statement
abgeben und einen weiteren tweet möchten
wir gerne zeigen der kommt vom
regierungssprecher steffen seibert was
in trier geschehen ist ist erschütternd
die gedanken sind bei den angehörigen
der todesopfer bei den zahlreichen
verletzten und bei allen die in diesem
moment im einsatz sind um die
betroffenen zu versorgen
blasius wenn wir uns noch mal erinnern
was in diesem jahr so alles geschehen
ist dann erinnern wir uns auch an die
amokfahrt von volkmarsen im februar
das war auch ein fall wo ein fahrer sein
fahrzeug vorsätzlich hier in diesem fall
wissen wir es noch nicht aber in diesem
fall war es so dass er sein fahrzeug vor
zwölf vorsätzlich in eine gruppe von
zuschauern des rosenmontagsumzugs damals
gelenkt hat um die 150 leute sind
verletzt worden
auch mehrere kinder waren darunter und
der täter hat bis heute nicht darüber
gesprochen was die beweggründe für seine
tat waren er ist auch nicht bereit mit
dem psychologen zu kooperieren
also für die angehörigen ist es immer
noch schwer zu verstehen was damals
passiert ist
nun weiß man noch überhaupt nicht was in
trier passiert ist aber wie kann es
trier gelingen gemeinsam über diese tat
hinwegzukommen
das ist eine schwere frage gerade in der
jetzigen situation wo die ersten
eindrücke erst mal noch wirken müssen
ich glaube dass wichtig ist natürlich
das was einerseits die stadt hier immer
ausgezeichnet hat nämlich dass sehr viel
zusammenhalt zwischen den menschen
herrscht und ich meine der stadt sondern
auch in der gesamten region
aber andererseits natürlich auch dass
von seiten der polizei und einsatzkräfte
hier soweit eben aufklärungsarbeit
möglich ist die haben gerade gesagt es
ist nicht immer möglich aber soweit man
das eben doch machen kann hier
entsprechend auch die öffentlichkeit mit
unterstützt wird und natürlich auch
andersrum seitens der menschen die hier
leben nun nicht in wilde spekulationen
ausgebrochen wird es hat beispielsweise
auch die polizei und ein portal
eingerichtet um fotos und videos
hochzuladen
damit die nicht einfach so im netz
landen sondern das ganze noch einen
gewissen
naja filter unterliegt und hier auch
vielleicht zur aufklärungsarbeit
beitragen kann
ich denke da ist es einfach wichtig
gemeinsam an dieser angelegenheit zu
arbeiten und letztendlich wird
wahrscheinlich zeit das entscheidende
sein
damit dieses jahr 2020 das erich schon
für viele sehr schlimm war und nun mit
diesem erlebnis oder diesem ereignis
noch ein hier vor ort besonders
schlechten höhepunkt erlebt hat dann
auch verarbeitet werden kann
da wird letztlich wahrscheinlich auch
jeder so ein wenig seine eigenen wege
ansonsten noch finden müssen
soweit das nicht hier in der
gemeinschaft getragen werden kann
ich weiß sie haben nur begrenzt zeit
weil sie natürlich auch selber für einen
eigenen sender arbeiten müssen
allerdings ist es so dass wir hören das
für 17 uhr eine pressekonferenz mit malu
dreyer angesetzt ist und es wäre schön
wenn wir noch gemeinsam versuchen
könnten diese pressekonferenz zu
übertragen deshalb würde ich gern die
zeit noch mal nutzen um einen kommentar
von ulrich pfefferer auf facebook
vorzulesen
er schreibt ich finde es gibt überall
kranke menschen in der gesellschaft
weitere spekulationen verbieten sich wer
meint wieder hetzen zu müssen der sollte
sich schämen ich lebe hier mit allen
menschen aus vielen ländern und kulturen
hier gerne zusammen das macht
deutschland als ganzes aus mein
herzliches beileid an die angehörigen
der opfer und die verletzten mögen
schnell genesen
vielen dank herr pfefferle für diesen
kommentar und wir blicken noch einmal
nach trier wir sehen noch einmal bilder
aus der trierer innenstadt wie sie sich
heute nachmittag dargestellt hat die
rede war von chaos in der innenstadt in
der fußgängerzone
ich sehe wir sehen die bilder gerade
nicht aber doch da sind sie genau
ein großaufgebot von polizei und
rettungskräften war im einsatz
herr blasius auch sie haben diese bilder
gesehen was haben ihnen die augenzeugen
berichtet
ja also die ersten berichte waren
eigentlich erst einmal die von ganz viel
blaulicht und sie reden was wir auch
hier direkt im in unserem funkhaus eine
posse wahrgenommen haben wir sind hier
unmittelbar nach der innenstadt und auch
an einer der straßen die jetzt noch
gesperrt ist und das war erst einmal ein
heilloses durcheinander die
einsatzkräfte sind gefühlt in alle
herren richtungen gefahren es war
blaulicht überall und die berichtet die
uns dann erreicht haben waren auch erst
etwas wirbel von einem auto in der
innenstadt auf dem hauptmarkt
möglicherweise von zerstörten ständen
und einem getroffenen kinderwagen das
sind natürlich dinge die man auf keinen
fall hören möchte oder auch sehen möchte
und dann hat sich die lage entsprechend
auch zu dem entwickelt was wir gesehen
und gehört haben nun die ganze zeit im
gespräch und entsprechend geht man auch
die berichte weiter in richtung wahrheit
und damit haben sich dann eigentlich nur
dinge bestätigt die man vorher gehofft
hat von dem man gehofft hat dass sie
nicht so sind es dann danke ich ihnen
bis dahin für ihre einschätzungen und
eindrücke aus trier gerne zum ende der
sendung weil ich höre dass mit malu
dreyer das noch etwas dauern könnte und
schwierig werden wird aber zum ende der
sendung gibt es noch ein statement von
bischof ackermann aus trier der ja auch
eine große rolle in der stadt spielt die
kirchen
der dom ist zum gebet geöffnet und um 20
uhr gibt es ein ökumenisches gebet im
dom zu diesem zeitpunkt sollen ebenfalls
im dekanat trier die totenglocken leuten
heute abend also gedenken aufarbeitung
der tat und die große frage was und
warum ist da heute in der innenstadt
passiert wir erhalten sie bei zdf heute
live natürlich immer auf dem laufenden
[Musik]